thank you
[Music]
there's a guy in NorCal on the street no
he's just honestly it's it's close it's
a dude in NorCal that um got out of his
car during traffic and then got hit by a
car and died
that's [__] awesome what do you mean
he wouldn't like that he said that I
know yeah he's an idiot right why do you
get out the car Nick what an idiot huh
yeah he's an idiot you know what I think
this guy's a piece of [__] because he's
stopping traffic yeah that's the Nick I
know yeah because you know it's the
purpose of driving is to keep traffic on
yeah I mean so anytime you just why
would you get out of the car during the
freeway really lay into him like get let
him happen what happened dude no it just
like
I'm not walking into this an [__]
right he's also your least favorite
sexual orientation yep because he's from
NorCal and he's like in his 30s like he
should know better than that I have a
top three a man gets out of his car in
the middle of traffic with a bisexual
man he was wearing a rainbow suit a
rainbow jumpsuit yeah with the piano tie
yeah awful oh you hate those rainbow
this way or this way
so what do you do what happened
what that what did the [__] do that
yeah
why did he get out of the car so he got
out of the car Jesse wants to know
because a family of baby ducks was
crossing the road and he got out to help
them cross no way and uh teen driver
that didn't see him actually crash in
him when he died holy [__] in front of
his kids his kids were in the car holy
[__] what's him being bisexual have to
do with it
you still you still hate this guy can I
tell you something I Saw The Little
Mermaid recently yeah the black one yeah
the one with the black chick it was very
good it was very good okay my least
favorite character the black chick is so
great
I saw that little mermaid huh yeah I
want that black lady in it
yeah The Little Mermaid was black I
don't know if you saw the cartoon one or
the live action one the live action and
there's a scene where Prince Eric is
like trying to be a gentleman and he's
like showing around town and all this
[__] and he's like hold on he gets out
of the carriage and he sees a farmer
with with a bunch of goats that are
blocking the the and did he kick the
[__] goat out of the way and he you
know because he's trying to be a good
guy he's trying to be Disney prince
right and he's walking by and he's like
oh we get these goats out of here and
he's like helping the guy and he looks
at Little Mermaid and he's like oh my
God what a sweet guy that's what he
should have done he that's what this guy
should have done he should have hurted
them heard of them I mean he tried yeah
he tried to like The Little Mermaid the
black one yeah he did get the Ducks
across yeah but unfortunately he got hit
by a car that's really sad oh no it's
sad of course it's sad
what's the context of him stopping it
was it like damn near right in the
middle like of the highway or was it
like a like a crosswalk or something
yeah I don't believe it was a crush duck
Crossings why'd you have to add kids
into the story yeah I just had that it's
in the store just said a drunk person
that likes to beat his wife and we all
would have been like yay I'm so happy he
died because we [__] hate people that
that stop traffic said hey his wife
should have beat him yeah yeah we would
have said that and he was trying to
catch the Ducks to make pet King duck
later
yep
I wish I had thought of all I've seen
duckling Ryan can you just be on top of
it a little bit more as a host as a host
do you believe in uh do you believe in a
person's past crimes
um being
anti-mercy when he does something like
if he dies then people should not
celebrate this person oh like let's say
he died doing a noble thing but he had
like 10 uh infractions previously he had
10 armed robberies or something oh then
I'm like kill that [__] even
though he was trying to help Ducks cross
the road yeah no I'm not against armed
robbery
I was thinking he was he was a bishop at
some [__] Church diddling away
then I'm like yeah the [__] run the
bishop over if he's around the bishop
over here
open the door so we can run him over
that's the only way that could they
could get punished hey he needs to come
out because we're trying to run him over
maybe or he's a cardinal I don't know
okay yeah I don't know what the [__] a
bishop is though but you would you
wouldn't stop to help baby ducks cross
the road I I think I would stop myself
but I don't think I would get out I'd
honk I'd flash myself the rule that's
the rule you're not supposed to leave
your car you're supposed to right yeah
that's the rule yeah yeah but also like
in the way was he if he's Advanced
enough maybe he could do like you know
like those police Maneuvers where they
start [__] doing the S on the freeway
yeah why do they stop the whole world
yeah and once everyone stops
like a citizen's arrest but it's like at
the traffic version yeah because if you
man like on a freeway that's [__]
crazy people are going fast where was it
I think it was just like a regular Road
oh so you're saying he's weak like the
team hit him at five miles an hour
too because he was in he he was they
said because he's a new driver he was on
his phone he's like a young teen yeah
they need to poke his eyes out yeah they
should cut his hands off I think that's
fair that's fair that's fair there's no
hands that's it dude he's nice no I'm
just kidding but like uh yeah so he he
did help the Dr cross and on it I think
he was on his way back from finishing
that oh that's like a movie so the Ducks
made it yeah the Ducks made it that's
like a movie because it's like Yay Daddy
and then he's like yeah and then he
walks his way back and boom picture it
now we'll never remember this
they'll never appreciate him and the
duck won't give a [__] they probably got
ate by alligator as soon as on the other
side dude if these ducks are just
[__] walking around on the street
being in the way all the time no way
they're gonna survive are you duck
judging dude I swear I have a lot of
ducks in my community and they get off
on being in the middle of the street and
they do and swans too they [__] love
just strutting out a little straight and
we all just got to sit there and wait
and they're like you know who else you
know who else [__] peacocks you got
peacocks where you live let me tell you
about peacocks yeah tell me about pizza
I are [__]
they're I we can get a bunch of teen
drivers that are new drivers to drive
through a bunch of peacocks about Acadia
you should just drive through Arcadia we
got to get rid of these peacocks man you
know those guys they Buck your cars up
loud too they cut it everywhere they
pecker cars never known this problem
because they see they see the uh
reflection of themselves in the car and
they want to fight yeah so they start
pecking at your door and [__] they do
that to really nice cars a lot yeah well
yeah if it's in Arcadia then imagine
them doing that to a Miata bro a 1999
Miata
some car
that's a real sports car
so you guys know the law when there's
like a animal on the road you're not
supposed to Swerve you have to like hit
it for real isn't that isn't that the
law that is the law you have to go
straight and just hit it it's the safest
oh my god well I guess I'm a [__] law
breaker
it's the safest because if you swerve
onto oncoming traffic uh people do that
when they try to avoid like a deer you
could kill a human being they could hit
a car what about bigger ones
like an elf even for bigger ones it's
the same like so you just drive into a
deer I guess so that's kind of what what
you're supposed to do this video I saw
of this guy driving with a dash cam and
he's talking to his wife on the phone
and he turns the corner and he just hits
a bear
just it's a bear the bear flies and he's
like oh [__]
[Laughter]
yeah but then he just drives off because
the Bears like gets up he's a little
rock uh I'm sure he's not like he's so
strong oh the bear didn't even die no he
got up and was like oh [__]
it was inaudible though oh [__] yeah I
was like oh [__] so you you sent that to
your wife no I didn't say that you added
it to favorites I just I just watched it
I just saw it so you [__] you found a
cool bear video and you didn't send it
to me dude okay oh [__] I'm sorry how
many cool baby videos I send you you
send me the ratio is like four to zero
yeah I'm just saying you sent me four
really good ones so my bad I'll send
I'll send you more bear videos I'm sorry
thank you so does that I know that's the
truth with like with deer and Moosh and
like cows or whatever but is that the
the um lots of like dogs technically
what you're supposed to do is look
around if there's a safe passage to like
change lanes okay to say whatever like
that's the rule right like you look over
real quick can you not and then and if
you can't you just gotta go straight
through and ideally you're supposed to
be scanning the road you're supposed to
be at all times do you guys want to go
around the room and talk about like all
the different animals we've hit Jesse
you want to go first go ahead I've never
hidden you've never hit an animal no not
even a squirrel that like runs in your
car it's totally not your fault Glendora
I squished one you never hit a rabbit it
like you're nicked it a little bit and
then you watched it like bleed out on
the sidewalk for eight minutes
I had a bird in my car I don't know how
it got there well inside the grill no
was it alive and I was dead it's fried
Jesus yeah it was like a road trip and
you're like there's a [__] bird man
how does that get in there so I think
because everyone has their own story and
sometimes it just you can't avoid it
animals are dumb though especially if
you live in like a like a rural area
area
you okay we're having a stroke
perfectly by the area you're pronouncing
I dropped the ball you messed up on the
easy
[Laughter]
the answer we have is the anti-asian
agenda bro back at it again I can't even
say it
yeah
can you say rural let's listen to the
writers say it yeah go ahead both of you
guys are right one two three rural oh
yeah
same way it was pretty good but like
hers was better you gotta do don't you
gotta break it into two words
break it into two words if you guys
activate your captioning and just tell
us who's not safe rural bam the rural
jerk and don't forget to put the rural
area don't forget to play this bad game
with your friends at a party
[Music]